coming to the show i am dr matt winning
the most positive name in comedy today
winning by name
that's it no that's it
there are so many shows focused on
climate change in edinburgh this year
it's practically a genre in itself
from comedy to contemporary dance to
polystyrene sheets and globes of this
unrecyclable product mainstay of ocean
pollution come alive in materia andreas
solustri's moving hour of object theater
in space hippo japanese shadow puppetry
tells the science fiction tale of a
dying earth the only hope a hippo sent
to discover new worlds in space
a lot of people
morons on the internet and friends of
mine would be like oh nature is here is
climate change fixed because of covert
it is a good thing is everything you
know is that a good thing and what i had
to tell people is um
no
i'd say the audiences are evolving more
because more people are becoming aware
of
it as an issue so the first year i
talked about climate change was 2017
and
nobody was talking about climate change
the uk summer of 2022 meanwhile will be
remembered as one of its hottest and
driest wildfires have devastated
suburban homes and host pipe bands are
in place to combat drought
it's no wonder that climate change has
become more and more prominent in the
arts and at arts festivals like
edinburgh as it becomes more and more
prominent in each of our lives the fine
line that every artist must walk though
is between telling truth that simply
frighten and telling truths that inspire
solutions and hope
have you heard
the end is coming
high above
the midday sun glares down
the air shivers in the heat
ghosts of the near future is described
as a cowboy noir fever dream about
extinction
makes you feel quite um
doomed
yeah can't say i leave feeling joyful
not hopeful at all
no no it's not like you're bog standard
this is about the climate and we're
going to talk to you about climate
change it was
it really made me feel something like i
cried a bit at the end
in this magic realist vision of a bleak
future there is neither hope nor fear
only the inevitable
[Music]
jonahal al jazeera edinburgh